jetzt habe ich auch mal gute Nachrichten
ne stimmt gar nicht bei euch war wollen
Missverständnis 150 Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler waren in einem
Brandbrief vor einer
vollkitastrophe ja Sie haben richtig
gehört
laut der Expertenrunde droht ein
kompletter Kollaps des deutschen
kitasystems bis 2025 fehlen
180.000 pädagogische Fachkräfte und
dabei ist die Situation heute schon
angespannt es ist 8 Uhr in der Früh
heute fehlt die Küchenkraft für Daniela
Rieth die Leiterin der Einrichtung
bedeutet das sie muss Frühstück für mehr
als 70 Kinder machen
bei uns
gibt doch einfach 20 Beutel Müsli und 10
Liter Milch in Planschbecken
können in jeder zweiten deutschen Kita
nicht alle Betreuungsplätze vergeben
werden weil Fachkräfte fehlen und das
obwohl der Bund vor vier Jahren das
sogenannte gute Kita-Gesetz
verabschiedet hat mehr als 5 Milliarden
Euro sollten die Qualität verbessern
leider wurde ein Großteil des Geldes von
den Ländern verwendet um die
Kita-Gebühren zu senken schön für die
Eltern blöd für die Kinder und am blöde
jansten für die Erzieher der Lärmpegel
liegt in Kitas bei bis zu 80 Dezibel wie
an einer Hauptverkehrsstraße das kann
auf Dauer zu Gehörschäden führen ja in
Berlin gehen manche Erzieherinnen nach
der Arbeit ins Berghain um mal Ruhe zu
haben
aber das soll alles besser werden das
Gute Kita-Gesetz läuft aus jetzt kommt
das Kita qualitätsgesetz diesmal soll
das Geld gezielt in die Qualität der
Betreuung fließen angepeilt ist zum
Beispiel für U3 Kinder ein
Betreuungsschlüssel von 1 zu 4 also eine
Fachkraft betreut maximal vier Kinder
das ist schön aber wo sollen die
herkommen laut Verdi überlegt ein
Viertel der Leute sogar aus dem Beruf
auszusteigen ja natürlich klar wenig
Geld kaum Wertschätzung wer tut sich das
an andererseits vielleicht sind gar
nicht zu wenig Erzieher das Problem
sondern zu viele Kinder
die Bundesregierung informiert alle
Bürger unter sechs Jahren hallo Kinder
findet ihr das auch voll doof dass Mama
und Papa euch immer in die Kita
abschieben damit sie zu Hause einen
schönen Tag haben können ohne euch
dann verzichtet jetzt auf euren
Rechtsanspruch auf einen Kitaplatz dann
könnt ihr jeden Tag zu Hause spielen da
wo der Disney Plus Account ist und eure
Spielkonsole und die Süßigkeiten
Schublade
[Musik]
denkt doch mal an eure Work-Life-Balance
also einfach Kita verzichtsantrag
runterladen eine Unterschrift reicht und
bald euch die ersten 100 Kinder die
verzichten kriegen ein Pony wie geil ist
das denn eure Bundesregierung
ein Pony da habt ihr im Winter auch
lecker Lasagne wenn die Zeit mal härter
werden
gibt es denn da sonst noch kreative
Vorschläge hier was ist denn mit
Quereinsteigern wir haben auch die
Möglichkeit eröffnet das 30 Prozent der
des Personals in Kitas anders
qualifizierte Fachkräfte sein können zum
Beispiel
kitasozialarbeiterin das Sozialarbeiter
aber auch zum Beispiel MusikerInnen und
oder Musiker
wenn das Michael Jackson noch erlebt
hätte
eines grundsätzlich eine super Idee oder
Bushido und Haftbefehl mit den Kindern
der Herbst der Herbst der motherfucking
Herbst ist da du [ __ ]
[Gelächter]
es ist absurd Kinderbetreuung ist ja
kein Geschenk des Staates an die Eltern
sondern an die Wirtschaft damit mehr
Menschen vor allem Frauen arbeiten
können denn dann haben die wieder das
Geld sich einen Kitaplatz zu kaufen
bei Ebay Kleinanzeigen gibt es ja auch
immer solche Jobbörsen und habe einfach
mal Kitaplatz gesucht also eingegeben
10.439 Euro für den Kitaplatz
für 10.000 Euro kann ich ein Kind drei
Jahre am Stück ins Disneyland Paris
schicken
und natürlich gibt es auch hier keine
bundesweiten Standards die Länderchefs
haben 2014 explizit vereinbart die
Qualität der Kitas nicht einheitlich
festzulegen wie gut dein Kind betreut
wird kann sich im Prinzip von
Straßenseite zu Straßenseite komplett
unterscheiden man kann Glück haben oder
häufig wird uns vermittelt zu sagen also
das ist jetzt wirklich sehr sehr hart
aber sie haben das Kind hier leben
abgegeben und kriegen das Leben wieder
ja vielleicht ist ein anderes Kind aber
es lebt
immerhin auf diesen Mindeststandard
konnte man sich einigen zum Thema Kinder
und wie man sie möglichst wenig sehen
muss kann man eigentlich nur mit einem
sprechen hallo Olaf Schubert ja hallo
du hast ja selber bis zu fünf Kinder
wie seid ihr an Kitaplatz gekommen was
ebay was Bestechung ihr habt das gemacht
mitnichten also ganz normal angemeldet
relativ früh also als ich selber noch
kita-kind war
habe ich mir die Formulare dort geklaut
und deshalb war ich quasi sehr früh ein
Mann mit einer Garantie für einen
Kitaplatz das stand auch in meinem
kinderprofil und das macht natürlich so
ein attraktiv wobei ich hätte natürlich
jetzt auch bei Ebay 20.000 Euro bezahlt
für so ein Kitaplatz ja also Ruhe ist
unbezahlbar wichtig ist natürlich immer
Quittung sammeln ja über alle Kosten und
dann hole ich mich natürlich hole ich
mir das also vom Kind zurück
jetzt nicht sofort aber dann irgendwann
wenn es mal arbeiten kann ja also mit 12
da korreliert sich das was macht denn
für dich eine gute Kita aus das ist ja
mehr als nur eine reine
aufbewahrungsstätte sag ich mal
unbedingt ja also es gibt natürlich
das liebevolle Storchen ist ja der
bringen die Kinder was gebasteltes mit
nach Hause es gibt die mäusekiste es
gibt aber auch das Rattenloch
ja da kommen die Kinder Heim mit
Schimmelflecken am Rücken weil es eben
doch eher modrig ist und vor allem ja
kaum digitalisiert ja also deshalb mache
ich zu Hause sehr viele digitale
Angebote auch im streamingbereich und da
muss man ja den Kindern auch mal was
zutrauen ja ich habe jetzt mit dem
siebenjährigen mal so ein Horror
schriller geguckt irgendwie das hat ihn
schon abgeholt ja also der der konnte
drei Nächte nicht schlafen und
andere nennen das Frühförderung und
ich finde das ist ein wichtiger Aspekt
die natürlich die Familie leisten muss
Frühförderung muss früh beginnen ja also
wenn die Frühförderung beginnt jetzt
direkt nach der Zeugung
dann ist es ja zu spät ja also man kann
da eher was machen also schon während
des Zeugens
dass man da schon mal Fremdsprachen
durchnimmt ja also Französisch
griechisch und und aber wichtig ist
natürlich eben auch dass man das Kind
körperlich fördert dann eben also bei
uns das klassische
Uterus Yoga für den Fötus auf Englisch
ganz klar Nüsse early bird ist thanging
Symbole
ja so wird natürlich ein Schuh draus ja
diese Woche gibt es eine große
Titelstory im Spiegel Lehrer und
Erzieher klagen über fehlende
Grundkompetenzen bei Kindern
dürfen Kinder heute zu viel würdest du
sagen also kapitulieren viele Eltern vor
dem Jahr ich sag mal König Kind ja das
wird man nie wieder das Kind als König
ja hier Kevin der erste
Rocco der letzte also
ich sag mal so Oliver die
es ist sogar
das ist das ist natürlich ein ein
Klischee ja also es gibt nicht nur
Tyrannen sondern wir haben mittlerweile
auch ganz viele kleine tyranninnen und
die müsste man erziehen so aber viele
Eltern gehen dann anderen Weg die wollen
ja eher die Freunde sein der Kinder ja
da wird dann so rumgekumpelt hey bro
Bock auf Müsli ja also ich meine da sage
ich nicht mit mir also ja warum soll ich
als Vater Freund meiner Kinder sein ja
also Freunde kann man es wieder
raussuchen so und ich hatte auch viel
gesprochen mit Psychologen und die sagen
alle es ist ganz elementar Kinder
brauchen Vorbilder nein da kann ich nur
sagen hier bin ich
und natürlich ist es ganz wichtig dass
der Wille des Kindes ganz früh gebrochen
wird ja also jetzt natürlich nicht mit
Gewalt oder nicht ausschließlich sondern
vorsichtig ja und da sagen viele ja das
ist den zu hart aber ich meine mir hat
es auch nicht geschadet oder
ganz im Gegenteil ganz im Gegenteil Olaf
Schubert
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh Gott der Dreh für die